[Music]
these are very exciting games a lot of
people are talking about these playoff
games and as i've already mentioned uh
this week people are also starting to
talk about the clothes that some of the
nba stars have been wearing to their
post-game
press conferences yeah it's pretty
interesting take a look it was just like
that in the first series against
charlotte you know they had a lot of
guys we got some good looks russell got
some good looks i think to go at one
i think we're doing a pretty good job
like kevin said we can always play
better it never feels good put it behind
us come on and uh just focus on the next
game it was just like coach one and uh
we performed we showed up uh we were
ready to play i think it's very unfair
for them to just call calls on us and
don't call no calls on them it's
ridiculous that's what it is it's
ridiculous we just gotta have our big
guys get more aggressive right now
that's that's what's gonna have to
happen next game but it's okay um you
know we're ready for tomorrow it was it
was a sandstorm
you're better than
[Music]